you should have been you should have
received an email that gave you
instructions to download all of the
software and things that you're going to
be using
in this next illustrious uh 80 minutes
i would like to introduce christopher
roach
currently at linkedin originally from
west virginia but in the bay area for a
very long time we consider him a native
uh and he's going to walk you through a
whole set of tutorials that are great
afterwards we're going to give you guys
um about a 10 minute break
if at that point anybody wants to switch
over to the other tracked and vice versa
we're going to try and set up another
set of people who can help bring you
back and forth i'm cindy if you have any
questions you can yell at me
otherwise i don't want to take any more
time from christopher christopher roach
everybody
thank you thank you uh
so so this is going to be
a lot of fun this is my second time
actually giving a talk at pi data so i'm
still pretty new to this
and uh let me see if i can get logged
into my computer
this is my first time though ever giving
a tutorial so this will be fun um
let me get the uh the presentation up
and everything so we can get started
it seems to have lost my
thing hold on
thank you uh just a second man like
the bar's gone
yeah
whenever i restarted it seems to have
lost it
i may have to wing it
the deck
yeah
maybe
software and
search for open reason
that's what i was just looking at
didn't seem to be in there
all righty uh
let's see
hopefully this is on here
ah deleted
well that's about the most exciting
thing that could happen in a talk right
there
uh so you all are going to get
one heck of a treat because my slides
just seemed to have gone away whenever i
rebooted so i'm gonna have to try and
remember everything from scratch so
fantastic
okay thank
you all right so i guess uh first off uh
so everybody knows that you know
downloaded the cloudera vm and
everything and the whole idea here is
that hopefully we can do a little bit of
coding along the way
so i'm hoping everybody plays around
with this
the basic idea behind this talk is that
about it
about two years ago or so
i started working at a small y
combinator startup and
we basically were looking at actually
processing our huge amount of logs that
we were pulling in and we needed a way
to do it so we looked to hadoop of
course and we were a python shop so we
wanted to find a way to actually process
those logs using python and
i proceeded to go online and try to find
out everything i possibly could and the
idea was that you know i would love to
have had just like an hour quick long
talk that you know went through and
taught me everything i needed to know
about writing my first job and you know
getting it up and running on hadoop
getting it up and running on hopefully
amazon
elastic mapreduce
which i'm hoping everybody may be signed
up for that the free version or whatever
maybe some of the libraries that were
out there and everything so hopefully
this is that talk for you
it will actually get you from knowing
hopefully almost nothing whatsoever
about mapreduce to
actually being able to write your own
jobs kind of understanding the paradigm
a little bit and being able to push it
out
onto something in the cloud so hopefully
that sounds good to everybody
i wish i had more visual aids now this
is going to be nice and fun
so i guess a quick little
background about myself i did have a few
slides up here uh for that or whatever
it's like i i've you know been
in the bay area for about seven years
like she said i've been working on i've
been working in cs for like 15 years now
it's like i've done everything from
embedded systems in like missile defense
all the way up to working on the iphone
and you know back to web development and
everything so
that's pretty much my background
i'm at linkedin now we do use hadoop a
lot um we use python around with with
hadoop
we tend to use scala a lot with hadoop
and everything too but internally we try
to use python as much as we can for
everything so it's a really nice tool to
have
so first off how many people have
actually written a mapreduce program
before
all right good i was hoping not a lot
it's like this is a beginner's class so
i want to really kind of like dig into
the fundamentals and walk you through
all this so that's good i was hoping
there wasn't too many people that went
through this
so um
let's see i'm trying to it's like bear
with me i'm trying to remember all this
um
so
the first thing is you know it's like
why would you actually need you know map
reduce um
i mean obviously the big thing is you
know it's like whenever you come across
a certain amount of data that is just
too big for your computer or whatever
right i mean you hear the term big data
all the time i tend to use a couple
different definitions of big data
uh one being you know kind of like uh
the idea of basically if you have data
let's turn it into something that you
can actually make actionable decisions
on or whatever right so that's i think
what the industry tends to use is big
data most of all
the more traditional definition and what
i consider to be the much more literal
definition is basically data that won't
fit on your computer
what do you do with that
typically you would basically pull up
your data you'd load it into r or load
it into you know python matplotlib you
take a look at everything and you would
figure out what's going on but
once you get to a certain size that's
not really a possibility anymore that's
where mapreduce comes in so
what is the benefit of mapreduce i mean
first off you know where does it you
know where does it actually come from
right i mean so if i remember correctly
it's uh jeffrey dean and sanjay gimawat
back in 2004 at google they wrote their
seminal paper
i remember the first part before the
actual colon it's called mapreduce
and it kind of introduced the world to
the idea of using this paradigm to
process large amounts of data
it's not a new idea i mean if anybody's
familiar with functional programming and
john mccarthy lisp back in the 50s
introduced the world to map and reduce
if you play in python and you like more
of the functional side you've obviously
come across the two functions map and
reduce
there's not really you know a lot to it
when you think about it map is just
basically a function
that takes a value and returns a
transform on that value it'll somehow
turn into something else
it could be as simple as an identity
transformation so you could actually
return the value itself or
one of the one example is you get a line
of data you get a string of text and you
basically output all the words in that
text or whatever so it doesn't have to
be necessarily a one-to-one
transformation obviously um reduce on
the other hand basically is just you
know applying the the addition to all
the different lists all the different
elements that are being pulled in so
well addition would be one example of it
so basically you're taking a large
amount a large set of values and you're
reducing them combining them into
a smaller set or a single number or
something along those lines so
does that make sense so far without
actually any slides or anything so
um
so now
what what does that actually give us i
mean now that you have this idea of map
and reduce i mean it comes from like i
said functional programming and what's
the big benefit of functional
programming
if you're into pure functional
programming basically you don't have
shared state you don't have any you
don't have any side effects whenever you
call your functions
what that allows you to do now is
actually parallelize all of your all of
your actual computation
so
let me see if i can actually get a
little
something up here
let's see
if i can make the font tad bit bigger
so
very simple version would be
okay
all right so this is your typical map
function whatever so
i will say it's basically going to go
through and square something so now
you're going to take in
oh sorry
yep
so simple function we go through we uh
take a list of items we basically apply
a uh um you know square to it uh sorry
that's multiply it yeah um let me
actually do
i'm sorry i actually like it better
whenever i'm doing that so we square
each value in there and we emit it back
or whatever right so the beauty of that
we have 10 values here what if we had
like 10 million or whatever right the
nice thing is that since
you know there's no shared state here
we're not actually we're not actually
changing anything we're not we're not
performing any side effects we're not
printing out anything we're not saving
to the file system we're basically just
taking a value and emitting it back out
the beauty of that is that now we can
start to divide this up into
multiple actual processes so i could
actually pull up multi-processing in
python i could divide my list of 10
million items into 10 different lists of
a million a piece or whatever and i
could run them on 10 different processes
and that's the beauty of map i mean map
and reduce it gives you that it gives
you that ability to basically
automatically parallelize all of your
all of your uh computation right
so
given that idea
what i want you to do i guess we're
going to go ahead and jump into a little
bit of coding here because
i don't have the rest of my slides to
run through so does everybody have their
laptops out does everybody have
everything they need installed
first thing i'm going to want the first
thing i want you to do is there is one
thing that you're going to need to
download
we basically need a corpus to work off
of
so
we're going to borrow uh a bit of a bit
of text from project gutenberg
i don't seem to be online right now
how do i get on the wi-fi
okay
this one
m0v
yeah i probably mistyped it
yep
just click show
and i lost everything my
it's like i don't have an account
all right
there we go so
uh do a quick search for project
gutenberg and
2852 that way we're working off the same
thing this is basically the hound of the
baskervilles
so the full text for that
and you're going to want to copy that
down so go to this plain text utf-8
are you human all right
maybe i've visited this too many times
now
obviously i'm not human
wow so can anybody think of any more
things that could possibly go wrong
on a demo i was like i am like literally
out of things that could i could think
of unless like a meteor falls out of the
sky on top of me or something
oh i didn't even see the one on the
right
so four three eight three four
six six
uh what was that
so
can everybody else get this down
oh we did oh gosh
fantastic uh you know what
it's nice to have a large amount of text
but it's not like you necessarily need
to i'm just
we are in demo purposes at this point in
times
fantastic oh please tell me everything
else is there
feel free to use the error text for your
uh example
oh you know actually i i do have the
text here thank god something actually
stayed on my computer
all right so basically um this is going
to be the most
like i mean this is the canonical
example of how to do a mapreduce or
whatever right
if you've ever done i mean if you
programmed obviously you've seen the
hello world this is the hello world for
mapreduce we're going to use it for
pretty much everything i'm hoping
a few of you haven't seen it yet because
the first time i saw it i actually
thought it was very clever
so hopefully a few of you would be a
little bit surprised and think oh that's
really neat how you can do that but then
hopefully what we'll do excuse me is
we'll take this all the way through um
each of the steps that we want to do
hopefully we're going to get this
running and just see how to do mapreduce
and then we're going to actually see it
on hadoop if everybody's got the vm
installed and then
we'll actually see it in a fantastic
library called mr job that's developed
by yelp and then we'll finally push it
out hopefully to
amazon's emr so that's the goals for
today
hopefully everything else goes correctly
so
how do you do this how do you do a
normal kind of word count here
i think for the most part
start off with a
import sys and just walk through the
actual standard end we're going to
assume that we're going to pass this in
through standard input
divide each line into a set of words
create a dict right and actually use
that dict to count all the unique words
seems easy enough everybody want to give
it a try
you want to actually
see what i have up here we can just skip
past that and
uh believe this is the right one yep
can everybody actually see that or do i
need to adjust the font
command plus
thank you
is that good
all right
so yeah pretty much exactly what we said
simple
loop through the loop through the
standard in
build a dict and
print out all the words after you've
counted them all so what's the problem
with this anybody
see any issue with this if you have a
large amount of data
what is it
sorting
store it yes
uh yeah i mean like you're you're
basically storing every last bit of this
in memory so you're going to reach a
point where you're going to take over
you know your the your main memory that
you have and then after that every time
you go through and try to access one of
those words i mean worst case scenario
it's actually going to push that out
onto your hard disk right and you're
going to be thrashing back and forth i
mean that's
worst case if you have something that's
too big for your main memory right what
if you have something that's too big for
you knows like that's best case there it
was like if you have something that's
too big for your computer altogether
your hard disk and everything then
you're really out of luck this just
basically won't do anything for you
whatsoever
so how do you actually turn this into
something that you can run on multiple
machines how do you make it parallel
so this is where it gets slightly more
interesting and of course this is where
you start to use map and reduce
so you have to be a little bit you have
to kind of think outside the box a
little bit i guess what i would say
so
i want you to go ahead and try these out
i want to i want to basically have
everybody doing this interactively right
so
this is your this is basically your map
function
so go ahead and start copying this down
it's only a few lines so it shouldn't
take anybody any time
very simple again we're just basically
looping through the standard input we're
splitting all the words
and this time we're actually doing
something slightly different we're
printing out basically the word and the
number one
so
now this is an example of pretty much
like a one-to-one
mapping that i was talking about earlier
so very simple imagine this is split
over to multiple computers now
easily runs you don't have to worry
about any of these things actually
conflicting with one another my map
function doesn't rely on another map
function actually going through and
setting anything
i mean yes technically we are writing
this out to uh the command line or
writing it out to a file but
the other map function doesn't depend on
the output for this that's the big deal
i mean that's the one that allows you to
kind of spread this out over everything
so has everybody got that copied down
so you can go ahead and give it a try
with you know it's like your text
hopefully you were able to download that
we're actually going to run this thing
through
you know it's like at the end of the day
it's like mapreduce uh you know it's
like there's a couple of things here i
mean right mapreduce as as is a concept
you don't actually need any special
tools to run this to actually see it
work you can actually do it from the
command line that's what we're gonna do
first
um
once you get into the actual special
special tools you'll notice that it's
you know a little bit more than that
there's a little bit more built up
around it there's an actual there's a
special um
uh a special like distributed file
system and everything that you'll use
and we'll hopefully see that a little
bit later
but first let's take a look at our
reducer
so now it starts to get a little more
interesting
so what you're going to do again is
you're going to loop through
standard input
everything happens in standard input so
hadoop is what we're going to end up
using that's pretty much the most
well-known mapreduce system
there's others out there
basically it's written in sorry it's
written in java and whenever you write
your mapreduce you'll actually write it
in java
one of the things that was created later
on for it was this idea of a streaming
library and it'll basically allow you to
use any language that you want to
interact with hadoop and actually write
your mapreduce jobs and the way it does
that is by relying completely on
standard in standard out
so as long as you write your functions
around this you'll be able to run it
against run it with hadoop and
spread it across as many machines as you
want and the nice thing about this is
that it allows you to kind of write your
jobs and test it from the command line
and actually do your debugging super
simple like that because once you
actually get into hadoop it'll be almost
impossible to debug anything
so
again you're going to run through
each line you're going to split them out
you basically get a key value pair here
so the key being the word the um
the value being the number one that we
wrote out earlier
and we're going through and we're
actually adding each one of these up so
the way the reason this works this is
basically going to take the output from
your map job that you just got done
writing but now if you remember your map
job basically just loops through all of
the data in the
pg258.txt file or whatever so those
aren't necessarily in any specific order
other than what the author intended them
to be in
but here you're actually going through
and if you notice we're checking here if
key does not equal previous key so we're
assuming that everything is coming in in
sort of a sorted order and that's a
little bit of the the behind the scenes
magic from hadoop that you get or
whatever right it'll basically it has a
step that you call the shuffle sorts
step which will take all of your
information from your map
function
and it'll go through and it'll sort all
of your keys and pass them into your
reducers so your reducers can always
count on the fact that they're going to
get a key and they're going to get a
list of all the values for that same key
that's why you can actually write it up
like this and we'll see this working a
little bit once everybody's got it typed
up
and
let me see if i can actually i want to
i did have at least
a couple of good images on here that i
remember where they are so
come on please be nice to me
i've obviously harmed somebody in a
previous life
all right so this is like you'll see
this picture everywhere and actually
there's a fantastic you know
representation of it
this is the shuffle sort step right here
that i was talking about
so you'll notice each you can you can
assume that basically each of these
colors represents like a specific key in
your data
so each of your mappers are all the way
over here on the left you'll have a
certain number of reducers
um
you notice that
the number of
like these are going to be files on your
on your hard drive basically notice that
they map up perfectly to the number of
reducers that you have basically what
happens is your mappers run on each
machine they know exactly how many
reducers you have they basically save a
file for each one of those reducers with
all the output from your mapper
and what they'll do is they'll basically
go through typically you can you can
change this behavior but normally what
happens is it'll take the key it'll run
a hash and it'll take that hashed value
and it'll do a modulo on the number of
reducers that you have and that way you
get two things out of that two nice
benefits one is that you get a fairly
even distribution of all the keys across
your reducers so no one's overloaded or
whatever so you actually spread out the
the computation
and the other thing is
you get this nice like you know sorting
step or whatever right i mean like
everything notice all the keys are in
one place so whenever what happens is
once your mapper is done it'll go
through it'll save all that information
into the different files it'll notify
the main node the master node that keeps
track of everything that's going on in
the system
it'll say look here's where you can find
the actual files for each reducer
the reducers will then be notified of
that and they'll go back to each mapper
and pull each of those files off and
that's how they get all their data
and then what happens whenever your
reducer runs they'll get that key so
you know in this case they'll get that
turquoise key or whatever and they'll
get all the values that you associated
with that key and they'll get them in an
iterator so you don't have to worry
about overloading your memory that way
either you can just basically loop
through each value as you go
so
everybody have this typed up
sorry what was that
uh you mean both of these yeah yeah sure
man are you kidding me you can have
every anything you want with all this
stuff's going wrong you all are being
nice to me
anything you can you ask for
see
you know i'm stupid
all right
that's that everything you're looking
for
all right so
i'm going to go ahead and run this down
on the bottom and i want you all to go
ahead and run it with me i'll leave this
up so you can actually see it
all right so
to test this out i mean this is
basically all that's going to happen
whenever you run it on hadoop you
basically want to
output the text from your file so cat
that
run it through your mapper
it's like unix comes with this nice sort
command so you want to pipe it through
there so you get the shuffle sort
situation
and then finally you'll run it through
your reducer
everybody got that
so hopefully if everything was typed in
correctly when you hit enter you'll
actually see all the the word counts for
everything
i'm
still see a few people typing so anyway
so there we go
ah simple map reduce that's the whole
thing that's basically the concept right
there so
i i i mean i still you know first time i
saw it i thought it was so cool
um i
like i started actually and this is all
my interview questions whenever we
brought new people in and everything so
if they'd never come across mapreduce
before
tried to keep on pushing situations like
this in their face and see if they could
figure it out on their own
uh
so
sorry
yeah
actually let me make this one a little
bit bigger too
there you go can you see that
yep
so now if you're doing pure hadoop
streaming this is how you'll write all
your code you actually do it just with
the standard in and everything and this
is the best way that you can possibly
test it right here um
that's the nice thing about you know the
fact that it's not doing anything
different than what you know unix does
normally so you can put in all your your
debug break points here and figure out
what's going on um fantastic you know
that you can actually do this
once you get into hadoop it gets a
little bit harder you can actually run
it on your local machine and start and
still debug a little bit but it's not
not the best environment to be in so
that's like why i really really love
this
so
has everybody at least tried that once
how many people actually have uh you
know the cloudera vm on their machines
fantastic
uh let's hope that i still do
um
go ahead and pull that up
uh what i want to try and do is actually
run this in hadoop
so we get a little bit of experience
with hadoop now
where can you download it uh
yeah if you just look for
if you look for cdh4
uh yeah it's
yeah
it's it's quite large actually um
so i mean if you want to if you want to
try this out later you you go grab the
cdh4 cdh5s latest but it takes like
eight gigs of ram to run it so that's
why i'm running this one
um
you can just follow along for the time
being i mean if you have hadoop
already installed on your system you
could use that too but it's kind of a
pain so that's why this is the easiest
way to go
just let me go ahead and get this
started up
oh thank god it's still
there all right so
i created a
virtual env earlier mainly just because
i'm going to have you all install mr job
a little bit later if you haven't
already installed it
or have it on your machine it may
actually come with the anaconda
download i'm not totally sure
first things first
to get that on your machine you're going
to want to go into uh
let's see devices
drag and drop if you go up to devices
and drag and drop you want to do
bi-directional
so everybody see that just set that up
so you can actually drag your files
across it's the easiest way to do it
and i believe i've already got mine all
here
yay okay
so and this is the fun part it's like
actually remembering all the
the things that you have to put in to
get hadoop running pro you know properly
is like
such a pain
so remember i said the actual streaming
capability is a separate library
altogether so hadoop actually comes with
a command called jar where you can
specify any any library jar or whatever
on the command line that's what we're
going to do here we're going to pull in
the actual streaming jar
so i need to we can find that first
actually i think i have it copied down
yeah here we go
all right this is going to be a little
bit harder to read let me see if i can
get this
to have a bit bigger
can everybody see that
so this will all be installed on your
machines if you have cloud error running
so hadoop jar
there's several actually streaming jar
files on here i don't know exactly what
they're all there for this one
definitely works so that's the one you
want to go with so user lib
hadoop 0-20 or dot 20.
it's a streaming hadoop jar don't hit
anything yet just type all that in
we basically have to tell it uh where
our files are and everything
oh
that reminds me i did forget one thing
open up a new tab
if you know how to open up a tab on this
so
if you type in hdfs so this is the
distributed file system that we talked
about earlier
so you're going to be playing around
with this a little bit
so i don't know why you actually have to
specify both of these
actually i take it back i do know why
there's a local file system too but it
just seems kind of weird to me that you
have to constantly say hdfs than dfs
then you have all kinds of commands like
you normally have on the unix command
line like dash ls and everything
so if you type that in hit enter
you probably won't see a lot i have some
things on here
but you can type it in with
just a slash
and i believe let's see
user there should be a cloudera user in
here yeah basically you're logged in as
cloudera right now so that's where
everything's located
so what we're going to want to i mean
what we're going to do here oops
we basically have to have our input file
the
pg2582 whatever txt file in hadoop's
distributed file system in order to run
the mapreduce job on it so we're going
to go ahead and copy that in now
so does everybody have all the files
copied over to cloudera
that are to their virtual machine
anybody still
the
yeah the map reduce code
mean this
yeah
so how many people have actually ran a
mapreduce job on hadoop
yeah yeah
not a lot thanks
fantastic
so all right
you ready for ready to run it or
doesn't have hadoop jar
oh uh
the hadoop dash zero tube
do you have hadoop on it what happens if
you just type a dupe uh version or
something like that
okay it's on there at least um
it doesn't take long to actually run
through this dude find
slash you know just like and then look
for hadoop star streamingstar.jar
um
on the distributed file system that's
what we're going to do right now
so yes we will definitely do that right
now
because if nothing else you can't
actually run it without it being on
there
all right so is everybody else ready to
go ahead and put their file on here
all right so like i said you have a
bunch of different commands
i think there actually is a dash cp that
you can use so it's a little bit closer
to unix but i know for sure you have a
copy from
local
so
it's actually really simple to get your
files up there
so i'm going to go ahead and copy this
one up you can actually uh specify a
different well actually you know what
let's go ahead and do that we'll play
around with this a little bit so do a
make dur
and what this will do is put whatever
you want in your home directory so you
don't have to specify the full path
we'll go ahead and
create our own word count folder
i may already have one on there so we'll
find out
and now if you do
hdfs dfs-ls again you should see that
your work count folder shows up
uh
that one's not doing it on here for me
probably not that one right
there you go is that better
all right so everybody got their word
count folder set up i'm going to go
ahead and copy the file in
oops so copy from local
and grab the pg file that you downloaded
or the error file or whatever you got
and load that into word count
if you want to give it the full path
it'll be user slash user slash cloudera
word count
and now you can just be sure that that's
on there
oops
misspelled
all right everybody got that on there
ready to actually run your mapreduce
if you have it on there go back to the
last tab where we
brought up the hadoop jar
so i'm going to try to break this up so
you can actually see it all
so now you have to specify your input
file both let's see this actually gets a
little bit verbose i don't actually
understand why you have to do all this
but
you're going to do each file so dash
file
specify the one you want
so we'll start off with our
our
input
which i forgot what the thing was
so pg in my case it's 1342.t
then we need to specify that that is
input and we're actually going to say do
that again
tell you a little bit verbose you
basically do this for everything
so you'll do file you're going to want
to do this for your mapper and your
reducer
so you should have something that looks
about like this whenever you're done
let me go ahead and type it in though
uh you don't have to copy your your
mapper and reducer in there just your
input
so uh
basically whenever first i'm
you know it'll whenever you tell it your
mapper introducer it'll actually
automatically upload that to dfs for you
so you don't worry about that part
and then you want to specify your output
so and now what's going to happen is
whenever you get done with it whenever
mapreduce gets finished it's going to
shove this onto hadoop's distributed
file system so you're going to want to
specify something there so you want it
to be in our word count folder so go
ahead and
specify word count output
all right i'm going to go ahead and run
this because it does take a little bit
of time but i'm going to bring up my
other notes so you can actually watch uh
look at it if you're
oh great
g132 oh come on
let's see if i
sold you
wrong
man i know it's there what am i putting
in wrong here
my favorite part of this whole thing
figuring out over and over again which
ones
all right let's see
all right let's copy that over
sorry
oh my god what the hell
you're getting the same thing i'm
getting where it's saying that the file
isn't there one
that one is a new one for me
let me see
this is one of the things that i liked
about the clad air thing is that it sets
up all the config for your
yeah i had to go searching around for
the other one too
so um
yeah
yeah this is the thing that i mean like
this is usually set up in your config
so was i meant to copy something
actually is there a config file for me
to copy i didn't
i mean that's that's the point of my i'm
trying to get everybody to use the
client actually sets up all the config
foreign things so i don't know why
that's not set up downloaded
this is five right it hadn't played
around with the five maybe they did
something a little differently on that
one like
i guess possible plus
yeah i know that one actually there's
like i just uh find it easier to use
file a lot of times
um all right
all right sorry let's see if we can
so hadoop streaming is located on a
different spot if you're actually on
cdh5 that it is here
um
it was in slash opt uh
yeah i was going to say if you run the
find command on slashop cloudera slash
parcels
and then look for
hadoopstarstreamingstar.jar that'll
probably find it for you
all right and now i've got to figure out
why it doesn't actually recognize my
my file
all right let me
2852
let's see
oh man i really have to apologize for
this i'm
terribly sorry it's like i lost
everything coming in
all right yay they finally ran
so once you stop typing in the actual
wrong number everything seems to work
eventually so
anyway that'll take a while to run
i want to make sure that everybody else
gets this actually running too so
who's actually having problems
error in a
oh that's a nice error
let's see here
i'm not successful
let me hold that a little bit
tired
uh so what is your what was your output
file uh folder
did you just do
word count yeah
just word counter
or word count slash output
okay um do a do hdfs dfs
dash ls on word count and see if the
output folder is there
another thing is have you
ran it more than once it gets really
so you have an output folder there
um
do
hdfs dfs
dashella or
cat
yeah space uh word count slash output
slash
part
dash
star
yeah hit that
come on
let's see this file directory uh do an
ls in the output let's see what's in
there
basically whenever you
run this so whenever you whenever you
run this and it's successful i'll go
ahead and talk through this
you should have just you should have a
if you did in word count you should have
an output folder inside of there you
should have something that says success
hopefully something along those lines
and then you'll have
a part file it'll say part dash i think
zero zero zero zero
basically the number of reducers is the
one that tells you exactly how many of
these parts files you have
hopefully that's in there and if it is
you can run hdfs
dfs
dash cat
give it word count slash output slash
part dash star
i'll type it up there in just a second
um i got logs and that's it you have
logs
let's see this is the fun part about
debugging now okay
um yeah yeah very verbose uh
take a look at your log uh you can do a
cat on that that exact same thing like
the one i just showed you maybe that'll
give you a little bit of idea well maybe
there's actually a bug in the um the
code or something like that
so this is the fun fun part of
so who else
all right go one at a time
all right let me just run this one
command for you real quick so if you
didn't get it successful you can
actually run this
uh
let me clear that
output
all right so
if everything executed properly this is
what you should have something that
looks like this
one of the things that
the hadoop system does it's gonna assume
that you're running this with tons of
mappers tons of reducers and you're
gonna have all these different files and
it's really good about just kind of
putting all these together for you so
i don't have one right now but if you
wanted to you could do what i was saying
you could say the the dash cat
word count
slash output
and then
part
something along those lines and it
should go through and cat every single
thing in all of your part files it'll
actually pull all of them together and
spit it all out for you
so
you probably need to see that actually
you should have something hopefully that
looks like that
whenever you run that command so if
everybody's went through successful go
ahead and run that in the meantime i'm
going to help out a few people
hopefully
so you had an issue and you had an issue
excuse me
kind of expected desks here
we're actually getting uh pretty close
to everybody having it done and um
actually getting pretty close to the end
that's actually dealing with hadoop is
kind of a pain so i want to get you at
least to the very last part before we
call it a day so i'm going to kind of
move ahead and i can totally hang out
afterwards and answer any questions for
anybody if you want to continue to try
and get this thing fixed
but i think for the most part just about
everybody's got something up and running
now
so um probably won't have enough time to
actually run this in emr but i'm going
to least introduce you to mr job has
anybody actually used mr job before or
heard of mr job
it's a really really nice library so
what you've seen so far is you're
actually using standard in to actually
read this stuff in which is fine i mean
it's it's better than writing java
obviously but i mean it's not the best
thing in the world
what mr job gives you is a couple of
really nice things i mean first off it's
going to take care of all of your
serialization for you right so so now
you no longer have to just emit say like
a keyword and a number you can actually
emit a python dict or you know tuple
whatever you want and it'll read that
back in and now you have like much much
richer data that you can actually do all
of your computation on so that's one of
the absolute biggest benefits it's also
something to keep in mind whenever
you're working with mr job you're going
to deal with the overhead of all the
serialization so if you do tend to run
into things that are starting to slow
down whenever you're using this it might
not be a bad idea to um skip the
serialization and actually go for pure
text and stuff like that like we have
been doing
the other thing is
is it makes it like super easy to
actually push all of your work out to
emr it's basically written around that
all of i believe yelp pretty much does
all of their stuff on on amazon's
you know in the cloud services and
everything so they uh it's just so so
simple to actually push it out so let's
go ahead and take a look at the same
thing the mapreduce using mr job